Hello.
Good afternoon.
My name is Alvaro Monteiro from Moffitt Cancer Center.
I'm going to chair this session on identification
and management of reduced penetrance high-risk cancer gene
variants. And there will be three talks.
One
started by Dr. Tuva Pal from Vanderbilt, then followed
by a talk by myself on functional
analysis, and then Dr. Bryson Catona will finish
that up as well.
So the way it is organized right now is that each of the
talks will be 20 minutes. We have a nine-to-10 minutes
discussion as well. But I think one
possibility is that because all the talks are interrelated,
we may have less questions after each one, and then at the end
we have a broader discussion that may be easier
for everyone to participate as well.
I think the learning objectives for today is really to evaluate
inherited cancer risk as a continuum.
I think really this is the key here.
And recognize the limitations of this binary variant classification,
particularly for these reduced penetrance pathogenic variants.
Another one is really to interpret, or give some
framework to interpret the functional and clinical evidence, which
includes some multiplex assays of variant effects, or MAVEs,
to identify and classify these reduced penetrance pathogenic variants.
And finally, to understand risk-adapted screening and
prevention strategies for individuals with reduced penetrance
variants in hereditary cancer syndromes, including Lynch syndrome
and APC-associated conditions. And the idea
is that this is really a subject in flow, so
every opinion is very welcome.
So we even have doubts about nomenclature and how we
should call different things, so we welcome comments
as well.
I think we'll start with Dr. Pal. Please.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you, Alvaro, for the kind introduction, and the organizers
for inviting me to speak at this session.
So like Alvaro already said, I'm going to be talking about consideration of
inherited cancer risk on a continuum and really set the
stage for some of the other talks as well from a clinical standpoint.
So again, really what we're talking about is
shifting our mindset from a binary
framework to a continuous framework.
And we published on this through a Points to Consider
paper
in "Genetics in Medicine" a few months ago.
And really, I'm using a lot of that paper to
frame my talk. I
want to put in my acknowledgements right away because, again, what I'm talking
about is not just something I thought about, but it was
colleagues across the US and beyond, including our
eminent Dr. Monteiro, who are on the work group to really think
this through.
So just using historical context and using the
BRCA genes as an example. In the 1990s, when
there were studies of multi-generational, highly penetrant families,
that's what led to the discovery of the BRCA1 and BRCA2 genes.
So it made sense to have a binary framework because
there was such a high risk of cancer
with presence of a germline mutation.
But over time, I'd say the lines have become blurred.
And this is a family that we saw in our clinic.
The original woman that got tested was
an 84-year-old with metastatic breast cancer, which prompted the
testing that identified a BRCA2 mutation.
Subsequently, her two daughters got tested. They're in their 50s.
They're unaffected, but they're positive.
And then the granddaughter is who I saw, 28-year-old, also
positive.
Now, this is a paper that we published late in
2024, and really it was
compiling a list of 16 consensus
variants in BRCA1 and BRCA2 that were classified
as reduced penetrance across two labs, Myriad and Ambry.
And this was work that was done in collaboration with those labs, as well as many
colleagues, including Dr. Alvaro Monteiro and Dr.
Fergus Couch.
And you can see the one I circle is one of the variants for that
family that I just mentioned.
Now, we look in ClinVar, and you see that it says
pathogenic, which again, doesn't tip off
the individual looking this up that there's something a little
bit different about this variant.
And then buried in one of the entries, you see it may be
hypomorphic, may present with reduced risk.
So again, my point here is that these are not always easy
to identify.
Now, this same variant was seen in another one of our families in our
clinic. And here you see 45-year-old unaffected woman,
but in the maternal lineage, which is where it's coming from, there are
multiple cases of breast cancer, some of which are early, and they
track with the
BRCA2 positivity.
So again, my point in saying this is, this doesn't look like
a moderate penetrance variant, right?
But this, again, reinforces the point that
even if it is reduced penetrance, we still have to look at what we're seeing
clinically with the patient. So the family history definitely still needs to be
taken into account.So going
into classification systems, this was
published
over a decade ago, the ACMG guidelines for variant
interpretation. And really it gives us three big
categories. We have the benign, likely benigns, which are generally
negative, the VUS category, and then the likely pathogenic,
pathogenic, which is generally what we think of as positive.
And it's important to remember that these guidelines were designed for
highly penetrant variants.
In contrast, there have been more recent guidelines
or recommendations through CANVIG UK that better account
for the spectrum of risk. And that's important to really think
about because this VUS category is better
divided with this. And again, what we see
is that some of these hot VUSs are the ones that are
the discrepant results in ClinVar.
I am told that there is an update in progress.
We've been hearing this for a while, but hopefully it'll be published later
this year through ACMG.
So here we have another family again that we saw in
clinic.
61-year-old female that I saw. Age 46, she had ER
positive breast cancer on the right side.
And then at age 61, she had triple negative breast cancer on the left
side. And genetic testing identified this
BRCA2 VUS.
You look at the ClinVar entry.
Eight labs called it a VUS.
Six labs called it pathogenic, likely pathogenic.
So again, this kind of raises the possibility, is
this a reduced penetrance variant?
And again, I don't have all the answers for this, but these are things
that we really think about when we're thinking about,
well, what are the strategies to approach these
discrepant results in clinic? What is the impact of counseling?
Because it definitely impacts our counseling.
And then the impact on cancer risk management.
And again, we really need to be thoughtful about that as well.
So another family, 24-year-old, referred for
risk assessment and testing. So this one's interesting.
The mom was the one who was diagnosed with stage three ovarian cancer,
tested through LabOne. So she was RAD51D positive,
which is an ovarian cancer predisposing gene.
And then she had this BRCA2 VUS. The proband
was tested many years later appropriately because she was very young
when the mom was tested. She was tested in her mid-20s, and
she had the same BRCA2 variant, but it
was interpreted as pathogenic. So again, two family
members that are getting the same variant identified through two
labs with different interpretations.
So when we look at the ClinVar entry, it's interpreted as pathogenic,
but then
buried in one of the entries, it says it may be hypomorphic.
So again, when we see these
discrepant results,
it may be hypomorphic. In this case, there were no discrepant results
because the other lab had not yet
inputted the information into ClinVar.
So when we're thinking about considerations, the patient interface, the family
member tested at different labs with discordant
interpretations of the same variant does pose
challenges, and we need to be thoughtful as we approach our patients with this kind
of information. When we're thinking about the mother with ovarian cancer and
the RAD51D positivity with the patient being
RAD51D negative, but both having the
BRCA2 positive result, which is likely a
hypomorph, does this impact what we tell our patient
sitting in front of us who's in her mid-20s?
And right now I would say no it doesn't because we don't have
evidence that the risk for ovarian cancer is such that we
wouldn't make a strong recommendation for risk-reducing
salpingooophorectomy
at a later age.
Recommendations for breast cancer risk management, I don't think it really
impacts breast screening. We would still recommend the breast MRI.
It really comes down in my mind to shared
decision-making regarding the risk-reducing mastectomy.
Again, the patient may decide to take this information into account to
either delay or forgo risk-reducing mastectomy, but I think
it behooves a discussion.
And then now I wanted to get to terminology.
So when we're looking at currently available terminology in
ClinVar, we have these two categories.
They're likely pathogenic low penetrance and
pathogenic low penetrance. Now, we've
had discussions and with the labs, they're worried that this low
penetrance suggests it's lower than population
risk, which is not what this is supposed to reflect.
So again,
at a national and international level, some of the consensus
groups have suggested reduced penetrance instead of low
penetrance, which seems to be more palatable to the labs.
It is something that
we've been having ongoing discussions about, and my hope is that it
changes. I think from a clinical standpoint, what would be
nice is just to have some sort of terminology that
tells us we need to
dig deeper when we see variants in ClinVar.
And right now I think that is missing in many of these cases.
So just going back to terminology, I've been kind of
using hypomorph and reduced penetrance pathogenic variant interchangeably,
but they are different. So with hypomorph, that refers to the gene
function.Whereas RPPV refers to the
resulting risk, so the actual clinical relevance.
And those two things are not the same.
So again, there have been a lot of functional studies,
both led by Doctors Fergus Couch and Alvaro Montero, that are
really trying to figure out functionally what are these variants doing.
In parallel, there's a study that's being led
by my colleague, Dr. Brian Shirts, who's trying to
estimate variant specific risks in BRCA1 and
BRCA2, reduced penetrance pathogenic variants, through building out
pedigrees and testing families, so segregation analysis.
And what he's doing through this is
offering family members free ancestry testing, which is optional, as well
as free genetic testing through Dr. Mary-Claire King's lab.
Now, beyond BRCA, there are other
genetic conditions where we also see these
genotype/phenotype correlations.
So with Li-Fraumeni syndrome, we've known for a long time there's
quite a spectrum of risks. Now,
this again is a family that I saw in clinic, and I follow many
of these family members that are positive with total body MRIs.
And what you see here is there's two women with early onset
breast cancer, their dad with prostate cancer at age
50. And again, doesn't look super
reflective of a low penetrance variant, but that is
kind of what is reported in the literature.
I'd been doing the total body MRIs, and then my
patient
developed a uterine sarcoma in between with mets to the lung.
So again, these are not necessarily families
that we can pull back screening on.
So it poses challenges because we know they don't look typical for
a
Li-Fraumeni syndrome family, but does reduced penetrance
really mean reduced penetrance in childhood, or is there
penetrance later on in life? And I think those are questions
that still need to be answered.
So when we look at the ClinVar interpretation, back in 2023,
it said conflicting interpretation, but more
recently, it's saying likely pathogenic.
So labs do update this information over time.
But with Lab 1 said, "But do not meet
Li-Fraumeni syndrome criteria, potentially an attenuated
phenotype." Lab 2 said, "Risk limited to breast cancer."
Neither of which are things that we are seeing in our family.
So again, more to be done here.
So going back to shifting to consider risks on a continuum, like I
was mentioning before, the risk continuum is based on interactions between
multiple different factors. We're talking about
gene, variant, polygenic risk score, as well as modifying factors.
And the risk contribution varies across genes, is dynamic
across the lifetime, which is really important to remember.
And the penetrance is organ specific as well as age related.
So when we're thinking about established breast cancer genes, there were
two studies that were published towards the end or in
2021 in the New England Journal of
Medicine. The Bridges study, which was over 100,000 women from
25 countries, as well as a carrier study, over
60,000 women in the US. And the bottom line here is they
showed very similar findings in terms of the genes and in
terms of the risk. So this, I would say, is the best data we have
thus far to tell us these are the main genes.
There are other genes as well, but these are the main ones.
Now, when we think of penetrance estimates, we think of gene,
but we're now also starting to think about variant.
We already talked about BRCA RPPVs, but there
is a BRCA1 variant specifically that...
So if we think of BRCA1, we think of it as one of the hereditary breast
cancer high penetrance genes.
But this R1699Q variant is one
of those BRCA1 variants that has enough of a
population frequency for us to generate variant specific
risk. And it falls in the moderate penetrance range very
clearly. It's in the mid-20s in terms of lifetime risk.
CHEK2, our favorite variant, the
I157T, has an odds ratio of 1.2,
1.3-ish, so well below the lifetime risk
of 20% for breast cancer.
And then we have the ATM 2424G, which
is a variant that imparts the lifetime risk
of breast cancer in the range of about 60%.
So again, what I'm trying to
say here is that even though penetrance estimates
are anchored to genes, I think we're getting closer
to certain times being able to anchor them in addition to
variants, and those variants may actually change
categories for the risk that we think of
on a clinical basis.
So when we're thinking about variant classification, we tend to think of
negative, VUS, and positive. And really what we're thinking
now is, yes, we have negative VUS, but maybe there should be an
intermediate positive and a highly positive
group.
And then when we get back to the NCCN guidelines,
these variants are not obvious in the NCCN guidelines, but they are in
there. They're in there as footnotes at this point.
I am hopeful that we'll be able to change the structure
such that they're easier to identify.
But again, as this list grows, we just need strategies to figure
out how we are going to share it with the
communityNow going back
to polygenic risk score, which is another level of
information that we can sometimes get.
When we're thinking about lifetime risk of breast cancer anchored
at 20%, if a woman has a breast cancer
risk of 20% or higher, they generally are
recommended to have a breast MRI. Now, when we
overlay polygenic risk scores over the
gene mutation status, it's really the moderate penetrance
genes that are the most impacted. So in
this study, which was again based on the carrier study, about a
third of CHEK2 and half of ATM carriers when you
incorporated the polygenic risk score that did
not reach the threshold of 20% lifetime risk of breast
cancer. In contrast, you see BRCA1 and BRCA2
are well to the right, so it doesn't impact risk
management as much for them.
So the impact of PRS is mainly on moderate penetrance genes,
but then
one of the things is the BRCA reduced penetrance pathogenic
variants are moderate penetrance genes.
So what is going to happen with them?
We don't have any studies at this point that overlay
PRS on them. So more to come on that.
Now going into the wider genetic context and other
modifiers, there was a study that was published late last year.
I found it interesting because it looked at hereditary breast cancer genes and then
the impact of family history of breast cancer, as well as additional
non-genetic risk factors. And what they found is
that the influence varied by gene.
So in my mind, this is additional data that would be nice to
incorporate into the risk models to refine the risks that we're giving our
patients.
And when we're thinking about why breast cancer risk is important and
refining the risk, it's really determining the risk that then tells us
what the management should be. Because with moderate risk, we
recommend the breast MRIs, whereas with high risk,
that's really we reserve the risk-reducing mastectomies in the high-risk
group.
So our goal is to personalize risk, and that
entails multiple levels of data, and there are
risk models to model these risks. There's CANrisk and
Tyrer-Cuzick that incorporate gene mutation status, but
really CANrisk is the one that incorporates multiple
genes as well as PRS at this point.
So CANrisk is an online tool, and it does
incorporate these various risk
factors to generate a score for both breast cancer as well as
ovarian cancer.
Then this is just the portal. What you get is a five-year and
ten-year risk, as well as a lifetime risk.
The thing is, the five and ten-year risks are much better in terms
of accuracy than the lifetime risk.
So this model does
all of them. But again, when we're talking to patients, we have to remember
is all models are wrong, but some are useful, and that's how I think of CANrisk.
Because at the end of the day, we're giving them an exact point estimate, but we're
not that good. There's a confidence interval around that.
So the way I think about it is, it gives me an idea of, are
they higher than what I would expect a certain gene carrier to be or
lower? So
it gives us an idea of what the next steps could be, and really it
comes down to shared decision-making.
And what's exciting is CANrisk version four was recently released and now
includes prostate cancer.
So here's another patient, 42-year-old unaffected female,
tested positive for ATM, and when we ran her CANrisk, it was
about a 30% lifetime risk.
And when we look at this risk in the
context of PRS, again, you see going from
just under 30% to over 40%. When we incorporate dense
breasts, it's mid 30, like 35% risk or so.
So again, you can see how additional data gives us additional
refinement of risks.
So when we're thinking about thresholds based on genotype, genomic
context, and other factors, really, I think we're going to
have to take all of these into account as we figure
out what the risks are. So just as an example, with intermediate
risk GPVs, if you
have more risk factors for genomic context and
other factors, it may put you in the high-risk category versus if you don't
have it.
And then with risk refinement and precision over time,
my hope is that we're just going to have smaller and smaller buckets
of risk. Again, I don't think we're ever going to be able to give an exact point
estimate, but we'll get better than where we're at right now.
So what's becoming evident is risk refinement is increasingly complex.
Communication strategies will be critical.
So in summary, cancer risks are on a continuum rather than
positive versus negative, which is, I think,
too simplistic nowadays. Genotype-phenotype associations
can change risk categories, and we're trying to figure out how that might
influence care. And then other genetic and non-genetic risk factors
may also influence risk.
So again, this is complicated information
to keep up with. We do have resources.
I think there are resources
broadly available, but we host this inherited cancer registry.
If anyone's interested, I have some of the resources there.
I just put this slide up because we do host case conferences once a month.
Dr. Monteiro is our guest expert in a few weeks.
So again, if anyone is interested, he will be talking about the
BRCA1 variants and refining classifications.
So with that, I thank you for your attention, and if there are any burning
questions, I'll take them. Otherwise, we'll wait for the panel. Thank you.
Kate.
I have a burning question. I have a comment.
I just want to make sure that we remember that there's more than just breast and
ovarian cancer out there, and that Von Hippel-Lindau
disease, in fact, has very strong genotype-phenotype correlations
that are well-known with type 2A,
VHL,
as you know, very of 2C, high risk of pheos only,
and sort of founder mutations that are also very highly
genotype-phenotype correlated.
And so I just want to point out that you talked a lot about breast and
ovarian cancer, but this is not a breast and ovarian cancer isolated
phenomenon. And certainly the issues in ClinVar about test
interpretation and reading the test are also very
pertinent to many other cancer susceptibility genes beyond the breast and
ovarian cancer.
Hundred percent agree. And the SDH genes, which I know are your favorites
also.
Yes. Completely agree.
Yes.
Hi. Very nice talk. So,
I have a question about this
discrepant results between labs that you mentioned.
One say it's pathogenic, the other one is not.
So wondering about their criteria.
How do they determine this is potentially pathogenic, this
is not potentially pathogenic? Because I saw in one of you, I was
trying to see the amino acid substitution, but I just
saw that first the amino acid was mutated, not the
one that's substituted. Because one of them I saw that
it's a highly conserved amino acid mutation.
So when it's a highly conserved amino acid, chances
are
it's going to change the function of the protein.
Yeah.
So I'm just wondering about criteria.
Great question. So what it is, is
there's different interpretations of the ACMG
criteria. On top of that, labs use their own internal
data differently and score things differently.
So they're using the overall ACMG
classification system, but they're tweaking it to their
internal processes. I don't know if Alvaro wants to comment further on this.
Yeah, I think the main comment is just to say that it's important to
recognize that ClinVar is also an open entry
database. So when the labs enter the data, they're
not necessarily abiding to any specific thing.
They have the guidelines, but they also have lots of their
internal data, and they're using that internal data to interpret the
variants as well. And many of that information is not
transparent or at least entered in the ClinVar
record. So we're left with some uncertainty
about that. And then different companies, for example, you're mentioning
about amino acid substitutions. Different companies or different labs
might have different predictors.
And these different predictors, they have variations, and
sometimes one will consider that to be
enough of a change to be considered pathogenic, another one will not.
So that's kind of the things that we have to deal with in terms
of interpreting the ClinVar information as well.
Yeah. So the idea is that in ClinVar, if
you're familiar with ClinVar, there are also
stars.
And the idea is that many of these uncertain
things will be one star and they're not
really
abiding to any specific thing. When you have two or three stars, then
they have been reviewed by a variant curation expert
committee or things like that, and then you have a lot more certainty that
they abide strictly to some of the guidelines of the
ACMG, for example.
Any other questions?
No? Okay. Thank you.
Okay, so we're going to shift gears a little bit from
a mostly clinical angle to actually talk about
function. Right? And I'd like to point out that those
interested,
Enigma is a
consortium that tries to work in that space and try
to identify what are the different characteristics for
classifying these variants.
Of course, a little bit restricted to breast and
ovarian cancer. But
that's kind of a lot of the interest has been in BRCA1 and
BRCA2 as well. But again, it doesn't mean
that the problem is restricted to these two genes.
No conflict to disclose. And I think I really like to
start with the definitions, right?
So and some of it is actually revisiting what Tua just said.
And the first one is this reduced penetrance pathogenic
variant. So basically, the idea is it's a concept that is
associated with risk. And one thing is also shown
here that something that Tua mentioned, that
sometimes because these risk predictions
and how we classify these variants have to do
being anchored on the gene.
When we actually plot this with other genes, you can
see that, for example, while a null allele of a highly
penetrant gene like BRCA1 is here at the very
top with a high predisposition. A null allele of a
moderately penetrant gene is actually a little less than
that and may be comparable to hypomorphic
alleles of a highly penetrant one.
So it's really the scale of this variance.
And the idea at the end is really to
moveTo some prevention or
precision prevention framework in which, of course, we
recognize that even risk being a continuum, that
medical decisions are normally decided on
binary cases, right? So you treat or you don't treat.
You do an exam or you don't do an exam.
So having clear thresholds is very important for clinical
management. But the idea is that we can move from what we
have today
to something that is a little bit more granular, so
that different risks can be accommodated
with risk-appropriate recommendations in the clinic.
The important thing is that reduced penetrance pathogenic variants, I
focus there also, the PV is in red. I
think we can think about that reduced penetrance.
There will be many variants that are reduced penetrance, but not all
of them are going to be clinically relevant, and that's what we mean by
pathogenic here. And the way we think about this, really,
again, these are evolving definitions that we're talking
about this region here that goes from two to four in
terms of odds ratio or relative risk, if you will.
The idea being that, for example, a relative risk of two
is
more or less what a sibling of a breast cancer patient has.
And normally, nothing is recommended for that person.
So it's something that is above that.
So the idea is that reduced penetrance pathogenic variants
are these variants that are clinically relevant, and they are
sitting right here in this range that might be
difficult to detect.
Thinking about how do they manifest themselves, I think there are
several ways that we can think about that, right?
So in one way is that simply that
the carriers of reduced penetrance pathogenic variants,
a smaller number of them actually developed the disease than
highly penetrant pathogenic variants, for example.
But we also can think this in a different way, in which, for
example, these reduced penetrance pathogenic variants
developed the disease at a later age.
That if, for example, you looked in a lifetime risk, it could
be the same. But if you now look at the ones that developed the
disease early on, that is where we see the
difference. We can think about the way that these have longer
survival as well. So there are many levels that we can
think about how we visualize these reduced
penetrance pathogenic variants clinically.
They may also have a different tumor spectrum, for example. Right?
So this is, again, borrowing from the
BRCA1/BRCA2 universe
in which we have, say, predisposition to different cancer
types. And in this case, we can think about that a
fully pathogenic variant, for example, will lead to
cancer both in the breast and in the prostate.
A fully wild type or benign variant will
not lead to cancer in breast and
prostate. But then you have other situations in
which the thresholds of how that function is
enough to maintain the wild type phenotype
is different in different cancers in different tissues.
And while it may lead, for example, to breast cancer,
that same specific variant may now still
have enough residual function that does not
lead to prostate cancer in this case, for example.
So there's all types of combinations of how we can think about
these reduced penetrance pathogenic variants.
So hypomorphs, right? So hypomorphs, again, different from
RPPVs, are linked to the concept of risk.
Hypomorphs are just linked to the concept
of gene activity. This was kind of described in the
early 1930s by Miller.
In which basically looking at different Drosophila
phenotype in the eyes and saw that
there was a really spectrum of
activity of different mutations in these genes.
These hypomorphs, so anything that has a reduced
activity.
Some of these reduced activity, much like the RPPVs, that not
all reduced penetrance variants will be pathogenic.
Also, it's the same thing. Hypomorphs are anything that
has a reduced activity, but not all of them will
have activity that is reduced enough that will lead to a
clinical phenotype. And it can be a
hypomorph at many different levels, as
long as it basically now reduces the activity.
And it could be
regulatory variants, it could be missense variants, it could be
splice variants. A number of different molecular changes can
actually lead to a hypomorphic
activity.
In addition to that, there's another layer of
where things are a little bit more complicated
in which some of these hypomorphs might be
conditional. Right? Or in some cases, also
called metastable. And the case is illustrated by a
couple of examples here. So this is kind of
early work in our lab where we
show that a specific variant was temperature sensitive.
And you can see that, for example, this variant
was considered benign when it was tested in yeast.
It was considered pathogenic when tested in mammalian cells.
And after a very long and arduous
definitionAnd experiments, nothing
changed. We changed several things, and the only thing that
finally we decided that was different between the two systems, at least
for the purposes of looking at this function, was the temperature.
So that now if we shifted the mammalian cells to 30
degrees, that variant that was before pathogenic now
became scoring as benign. And if we put the
yeast cells at 37, now that would lead to
a pathogenic score. And the idea being that some of these
variants are hypomorphs because they are not
stable proteins after they're synthesized.
And in some cases, for example, a lower temperature, they may be
stable enough to produce all of the activity needed, but
once you increase the temperature, that is a
problem. We have some examples of P53 mutations like
that. They're also more dependent on a pH
and anoxic conditions in which the mutations are
relatively okay in normal conditions, but once they are
in a high pH or anoxic condition, that variant is
now
hypomorphic.
Right? And this work is also illustrated
by work from MD Anderson, in which it was
shown that many of these characteristics
can be buffered by heat shock proteins, which help
stabilize these proteins. So depending on the
levels of HSP 90, for example, or other heat
shock proteins and chaperones, that particular variant may
be stabilized in different tissues or even in different
individuals, even though the variant is the same.
So there's several levels, just much like in
the way that risk from specific variants are modified by
polygenic risk score. We also have variants that
have their activity modified by the
conditions in the cell or in the condition in the tissue.
So the idea here is how do we
identify these reduced penetrance variants, right?
So, as you know, conducting
risk determination in variants that are very rare
is very, very difficult. In many of the studies that we have to
estimate risk right now, they're done with variants in
aggregate. We compile all the missense variants
and we estimate the risk. But there's very few variants that the
allele frequency in the population is enough that we
have a really good risk estimate. So one
idea here is basically try to use functional
data to try to identify these variants.
And this is shown here in which
we assume that there is a correspondence between
activity and risk. This is a tumor suppressor gene.
The lower the activity, the higher the risk.
And we would be looking for variants that would be sitting here in the
middle. These reduced penetrant pathogenic variants that have
reduced activity but still leads to a clinical phenotype.
So again, much like the experiments in
Drosophila,
we
started pursuing some of these variants that became a little
bit outlier observations in the lab.
And they were hypomorphs. That's how we identified in the
lab through functional analysis.
And eventually, they turn out to be reduced penetrance pathogenic
variants, what actually gives us some framework and
some foundation to hypothesize by doing
large-scale functional analysis, we can identify a
large number of these
reduced penetrance variants in the population.
And here, for example, is an example of an earlier study in
which we did just simple linear regression, and we saw
here that there were two variants that although they
were
predicted to be a different thing, they actually
scored as an outlier, for example.
And here we have the R1699W,
which is a cousin of the R1699Q
that Tuwa talked about,
and also the V1736A.
And basically, this was a variant that had been
classified in BRCA1, had been
classified as
pathogenic and basically-- sorry,
as benign. And
it was weird because we had information that this was
really something that affected function.
But there were information from family data that suggested
that this variant was not pathogenic. Right?
But then what we found out was that this variant was
actually part of a family in which
there was a biallelic deleterious
combination. And that family had some
characteristics of Fanconi anemia.
So when that variant was classified
in BRCA1, because it was co-occurring with another
variant, which is something that is used to classify pathogenic
variants in BRCA1, it suggested that it was
not going to be pathogenic and yet turned out to be a
hypomorph. And that's why it was possible to find in the
same patient co-occurring with another pathogenic
variant.And so there's kind of several
instances here that we, over the
years, have been identifying these variants that were pointed out to
us because they were outliers in functional analysis.
And as we delved into family
or population studies, they were shown actually to
be reduced penetrance pathogenic variants.
So the idea
that we need some quantitative way to do functional
analysis, and here is one example
from our work, where we have a VARcall model that
basically transforms protein activity that
we obtain in a certain assay in vitro to the
probability of pathogenicity. And this is just a
two-component mixture model in which we think that the
distribution of activity, which is shown here on the
side, is a mixture of two components, a neutral
and a pathogenic component. But as you see here,
on top, we see all the variants that are neutral, and
on the bottom, you have the pathogenic component.
But as you see here, we have a large number of variants that
fall in the middle. And these are variants that we think
have a high chance of being of reduced penetrance.
In the latest MAFs, both by
Jay Shendure's lab from Greg Findley, but
also a recently published work by Dr.
Couch here. We also show that basically we can
use these large-scale variant analysis to
identify variants that are in the middle here,
that are not clearly pathogenic nor clearly
benign as variants that may be of reduced
penetrance.
Interestingly, this is an analysis that isn't published yet, and
what you see on the top is actually the frequency of
variants that score as pathogenic in functional analysis in
BRCA1 and BRCA2, shown in red at the
top. But also we have, at the bottom, variants
that score as hypomorph. So these are variants that are
intermediate in the functional assays.
And what we see is that basically these variants tend to
collocate with the complete loss of function
variants, suggesting that these regions of the
proteins are really sensitive and changes
may lead to a complete loss of activity, but they may
also lead to a partial
reduction in function.
So can we use functional analysis to identify these variants?
Yes, we can.
But the question is, which of these functions are we looking at,
right? So as far as we're trying to predict
pathogenicity, as long as a functional assay
has high sensitivity and specificity, it may be
tangentially related to the actual molecular function as
long as it's a good predictor. However, if now
we're doing a slightly different thing, which is to try to
point out which of these variants are going to be a reduced
penetrance, we need to figure out exactly which
functions are actually leading to cancer risk.
And this is not really trivial.
So one of the approach that we're pursuing right now
is really to try to establish the relationship
between these hypomorphic variants and the reduced penetrance
pathogenic variants in which we do a functional assay.
For example, we identify the variants that are in this
intermediate range, and then we look whether they
are validated, for example, in additional assays.
And then we go out and try to estimate their
penetrance so that we can now identify at least
a few of them that can act as anchors
for us. Right? So the idea is demonstrated
here in which we have variants with
high risk,
variants with low risk, and we're trying to correlate that
with low activity and high activity.
But the question is, how do we
decide on the
thresholds? And that's why, as of today,
what we have is that we may have some of these misclassified
variants because we don't have a good handle on
how we adjust the thresholds from risk into
activity. And that's what we call calibration, and if we're
able to use at least a few of these variants
that can be demonstrated in functional analysis,
validated in risk analysis, and then they can ask as a
way to adjust these thresholds, then now we
can go out and have a much larger
scale identification of these variants that can then
be used to apply for clinical recommendations.
So
again, just summarizing here, the idea is that we're going to
go from what it is today, this
binary of pathogenic, likely pathogenic versus
likely benign or benign, into something that is a little bit more
granular. That, for example, now we have a
pathogenic high risk and pathogenic intermediate, and that may
lead to different clinical recommendations.
For example, you can imagine that a variant
that is pathogenicMay still trigger recommendations for
enhanced screening and MRI for breast cancer, but you would not
offer prophylactic surgery for these patients, for example.
And then eventually we can go in and start building on
that model to have better ways of risk
assessment and clinical management of these patients.
And at the very end, I'd like really to leave you with this
burning question, which is very specific to all the
genes that are in the homologous recombination
pathway, BRCA1, BRCA2,
PALB2,
is really how do these tumors
in RPPV carriers respond to therapy,
specifically PARP inhibitors? So that's an open question,
and I think it's fair to say that we've seen evidence
in both ways, but we do not have a final
answer yet.
And I'll stop here and take questions if there are any. Thank you.
Hello. Soraya Dorabi from Hogue. Thank you for the presentation.
I had two questions, but one of them was your last question, so how about tumors?
Could we use HRD assays
that are currently available as a functional?
That's what we really struggle in a clinic when there is a mutation
outside BRCA2 and there is no HRD positivity coming
up with tumor. Should the patient get treated with PARP inhibitor or
even if they're sensitive to platinum base? Thank you.
Yeah. So I think there are probably better people to answer that
than myself. I think
any type of HRD score, I think is going to be tremendously
informative. And I think
we try to do this in the paper that we
published a list of consensus variants, but we didn't have enough
data
going one way or the other, right? So, just what
are these tumors? But I would think that clinically,
if the tumor scores as deficient,
I think there would be a good chance that we'll respond to PARP
inhibitor, independent of what variant it is.
So I think it's a way, a little bit, to bypass whether
the specific variant is or is not of
high risk. So if the HRD
points that way, I would be
really confident that it might respond to PARP inhibitors.
Is that a fair assessment?
Yeah, but I think the question is, what if it's not?
Would you still-
Correct. Yes.
Yeah. And that I think the jury's out, I think at this point.
There's oncologists in the audience-
Correct. Yeah
... that would be more qualified to talk about this.
But
I do think that if there's a germline
mutation in BRCA1 or BRCA2, PARP is on the table,
and right now we're not necessarily using the molecular
characteristics. Maybe that will change over time because biallelic
inactivation would be another
kind of thinking. Do those tumors respond the
same way to PARP? We don't know the answer to that at this point.
Yeah. And I think sometimes is what other
options do you have, right? I think that might be a consideration as
well. I don't know. Bryson, do you want to chip in on that or
?
Yeah. As a gastroenterologist, I may have to pass on that.
Okay. That's good. But in the context of
anything that you can think of,
we're trying to figure out these things as well.
So I think there will be data coming very soon
about all of these HRD scores and these different
kind of measurements of what's happening in the tumor for us to have a better
decision.
Okay. Any other questions?
No. Okay. So we'll go on to the next one, Dr. Catona.
All right. Well, I'd like to thank Alvaro for putting this session together
and for the invitation to speak today.
What I'm going to be talking a little bit about are the clinical challenges
associated with management of these reduced penetrance
pathogenic variants. These are my disclosures, which are not relevant.
So first, what we're going to cover today is I'm going to talk a little more
broadly about some of the management challenges that can come
up with management of these reduced penetrance variants.
And then as a gastroenterologist, we've been talking a lot about breast cancer.
I'm going to throw the digestive tract a little bit of love and talk about
FAP, including both attenuated and classic FAP, and how
management of reduced penetrance variants in FAP is quite
easy given that we follow a phenotype-directed approach.
And then I'm also going to be talking about Lynch syndrome and some of the reduced
penetrance variants in Lynch syndrome, and then talk about some of the
management challenges when you cannot use a phenotype-directed
management approach.
All right. So when you have a patient who's at increased cancer risk due
to a genetic predisposition, when you think about developing a
plan for their risk management, there's many factors that are going to contribute
to that, including what is the actual cancer risk associated with the
variant that they carry? What are the screening and/or potential
surgical options that this individual may be eligible for because
of this risk?
How and when should this management be incorporated
into their care? And of course, with any screening or surgical
options, you have to think about what are the risks of those screening
tools and/or surgeries, and are those risks that the
patient
will be willing to take. But there are many other challenges that arise
here. So as has been highlighted earlier, there is a lack of
robust variant-specific risk data to help us make these
decisions. There are differing lab classifications.
A lot of our guidelines don't necessarily address the reduced
penetrance variants, althoughAs Tuo pointed out, the NCCN
is doing a much better job at that, especially in the breast
guidelines. Sometimes patients that carry these variants get mixed
messages between providers, and it's also very difficult
to communicate this type of reduced risk to a patient.
So if you see a patient, especially if they have lower health literacy, and you
tell them, "You are on the lower end of a high-risk spectrum," they're going to
have no idea what you're talking about.
And then, of course, I think for these reduced penetrance variants, there's also
a very high risk of overmanagement of
the risk.
So let's go through a couple different examples about how you can think about
different screening tests and risk management strategies for someone who is
a reduced penetrance variant carrier.
So when you think about non-invasive screening tests, so mammograms, PSAs,
things like that, if you have somebody who carries a reduced penetrance
variant, you have to ask, well, is this non-invasive screening test even
needed at all for this individual?
And if it is, do you need to start this potentially at a later age, or
do you potentially have to change the frequency and do it less often?
For invasive screening tests, so thinking about colonoscopies or endometrial
biopsies, if you have somebody with a reduced penetrance variant, are these
invasive tests actually needed, or could we potentially switch this
person over to a non-invasive screening test as an
alternative? And additionally, can these tests be
done at a later point, or can the interval between tests be longer?
And then when we think about risk-reducing surgery, such as a
hysterectomy with bilateral salpingo-oophorectomy,
the question to ask there for a reduced penetrance variant carrier,
is the surgery needed, or can you forgo surgery and instead
actually do some sort of screening for this individual as well?
And if you do move forward with surgery, can the surgery be performed later, or
maybe the surgery doesn't need to be as extensive as
someone that has a different variant in the gene.
And just focusing in on these last two, because these are discussions that I think
we have oftentimes with patients across the hereditary
spectrum. But when you think about screening tests, the things that
you're always highlighting to patients are that the benefits of screening
compared to moving forward with a risk-reducing surgery is that, of course, you
don't have to go through surgery, and you don't have any of the immediate or
long-term risks associated with a risk-reducing surgery.
But these individuals obviously still need to do the screening,
and screening itself may have risks, and the cancer risks remain
elevated. But in the setting of a preventative surgery, the
things to highlight to patients are that, yes, this may definitely reduce the
need for and/or the potential extent of screening and definitely reduces
cancer risk. But of course, this is an irreversible surgery that can be
associated with risks. And so these are a lot of the points that we
debate with all patients who carry hereditary cancer predisposition.
But
may certainly have to be addressed in more detail with those who are
carrying reduced penetrance variants.
All right. So I want to move on to talk a little bit about FAP.
So just to level set a little bit for those who may not live in the GI genetics
world, FAP or familial adenomatous polyposis is
the most common hereditary polyposis syndrome and the
second most common cause of hereditary colorectal cancer following Lynch
syndrome. It's caused by pathogenic variants in the
APC gene. And we have two different forms of
FAP. We have classic FAP and attenuated FAP.
So I think this is actually the ideal condition in my mind to think about
management of reduced penetrance variants, because classic FAP
basically results from high-risk variants, and
attenuated FAP basically results from reduced penetrance variants
in APC. So between the two, classic
FAP are the individuals where they're developing hundreds to thousands of
colorectal polyps over their lifetime, typically starting in the teenage years
with a near 100% risk of developing colorectal cancer if they
don't have some sort of preventive approaches taken.
Whereas attenuated FAP, they develop fewer polyps.
These polyps develop later in life.
And if colorectal cancer develops, usually it's at a later
onset.
Now, FAP is not just a syndrome that impacts the colon.
It also impacts many other areas throughout the body.
Within the luminal GI tract, these individuals are at risk for upper GI
polyps, including polyps in the stomach, both fundic gland polyps and gastric
adenomas, as well as polyps in the duodenum, which you can see here
on the picture on the right, where they can develop duodenal and
ampullary adenomas and certainly have an increased risk of both gastric
cancer and duodenal and ampullary adenocarcinoma.
They develop tumors outside the digestive tract, including desmoid tumors and
papillary thyroid cancers, and they have many other manifestations
as well, including CHRPE, which is a
finding that's found in the back of
the retina. It's often picked up incidentally.
Now, the neat thing about FAP is that there is a
very, very strong genotype-phenotype correlation.
And so the APC gene is a large gene, has over 2,800
codons. What we know is that where the mutation occurs
in the gene really is very predictive of what the phenotype will be
for these individuals. With the most severe phenotypes
being these genes in the beta-catenin binding domain of
APC, whereas individuals who have mutations in the five-prime
end or in the three-prime end, having a much more attenuated or
reduced penetrance version of
FAP.Importantly, a lot of the other manifestations
outside of colorectal polyps also follow this genotype-phenotype
correlation. For example, desmoid tumors here are primarily seen
in individuals who have more 3'
shifted mutations.
And this really holds true. So if we think about this particular
APC variant here that impacts
the 5' end of the gene, this is one of the more common
attenuated FAP variants in the United States and is often being
called an American founder, but it really does have a very
attenuated polyposis phenotype.
Whereas opposed to this particular variant here that impacts the
1309 codon, which is really a hotspot for developing the most profuse
polyposis, this particular gene has a very
dramatic
phenotype, where affected individuals are often needing
colectomy prior to age 20.
But what's nice about having this genotype-phenotype correlation
is that we can use the phenotype to direct our
management for FAP. And so if you have a reduced
risk
variant or reduced penetrance variant in FAP, you're
basically using the polyp phenotype to
determine how you manage that particular individual.
So when we think about upper GI polyp management in FAP,
specifically in the duodenum, what we follow is something called the
Spiegelman score, which takes into account the number of polyps an
individual with FAP has in the duodenum, as well as the size of these
polyps and some histologic features.
And we use that Spiegelman score to get a Spiegelman stage.
So if you have a score of zero, basically meaning that you don't have any duodenal
polyps, that gives you a Spiegelman stage of zero and
leads to an upper endoscopy follow-up interval of somewhere between three to
five years. If you have a Spiegelman stage of one,
meaning you probably have a couple small polyps in the duodenum, that
surveillance interval goes down a little bit to two to three years.
A Spiegelman stage II, you tell these patients to get an upper
endoscopy every one to two years. Spiegelman stage III, it's every six to 12
months. And when you get to a Spiegelman stage IV, you're doing very short interval
upper endoscopy or you're sending these patients for surgery.
And so this is very nice because if you have a reduced penetrance
APC variant, you're basically managing the upper GI
tract based on what the polyp burden looks like.
And so management in this case, again, when it's phenotype directive, is
very easy to do.
We similarly do this for colorectal polyp management in
FAP as well.
In classical FAP, individuals will typically start
colonoscopy somewhere between age 10 to 15, and
people with classical FAP basically will need a colectomy at
some point because they're developing thousands of polyps.
The question is, when will that colectomy be needed?
And so we start colonoscopy between age 10 to 15 and repeat
this yearly until the polyp burden is increasing to a
point where we think, okay, colectomy is needed.
Now, in attenuated FAP, patients start colonoscopy a little bit
later, but again, we use the phenotype of the colons to direct
how frequently or how we should manage that colorectal polyp burden.
So if they have minimal polyp burden, maybe they can get away with getting a
colonoscopy every two years. If they have an endoscopically, we'll
say manageable polyp burden, because manageable
has a different definition for every gastroenterologist.
But if you can handle the polyps every year, they may be getting a colonoscopy
every one year. And for some of these patients, eventually they may need to go on
to colectomy because of a high polyp burden.
But again, really focusing on the fact that because we have a phenotype
that is basically directly proportional to the risk, we can use that
phenotype to guide management,
which is incredibly important for these reduced penetrance variants.
Now I want to switch gears to Lynch syndrome, because in Lynch syndrome,
when thinking about managing reduced penetrance variants, we do not have that
phenotype to help us, and so it becomes a little bit more difficult.
So let me just level set a little bit for Lynch syndrome.
Lynch syndrome is the most common hereditary colorectal cancer syndrome,
impacting about one in 300 individuals.
It's actually more common than having a BRCA1 or 2 mutation, which I think a lot
of people don't realize.
There are five different genes that are associated with Lynch syndrome, and these
genes impact the mismatch repair system.
And there are many different cancers where risk is increased in Lynch syndrome.
Colorectal and endometrial cancer have the highest risk, but there are
other digestive tract cancers such as gastric cancer, small intestinal cancer, and
pancreatic cancer, where risk is increased.
There's other cancers outside of the digestive tract too, such as urinary
tract cancer, ovarian cancer, prostate cancer, and sebaceous
skin cancer, where risk is increased as well.
Now, thinking about Lynch syndrome more broadly, before we get into specific
reduced penetrance variants.
When we manage cancer risk in Lynch syndrome, kind of a baseline,
we use a gene specific approach. And so let's think about
this for colorectal cancer surveillance in Lynch syndrome.
Looking at cumulative colon cancer risk data, what you can see
here is that carriers of an MLH1 or MSH2 mutation
clearly have higher risks of colorectal cancer, and that risk starts to
increase at younger ages compared to MSH6 and
PMS2 carriers. Because of that, we adjust how
we implement screening in these individuals.
So for these higher risk genes, we're starting colonoscopy somewhere between age
20 to 25, and we're repeating colonoscopy every one to two
years. But for the
lower penetrance MSH6 and PMS2 genes, we're starting
colonoscopy a little bit later, between 30 to 35, and repeating
colonoscopy potentially up to every three years.
So we're using the gene in this case to drive the
cancer risk management strategies.
A similar approach is used for gynecologic cancer risk
management.And specifically, we'll talk about endometrial cancer
risk management in Lynch syndrome.
And what you can see here is that for endometrial cancer, there's a big difference
with PMS2 being a remarkably reduced penetrant
gene compared to all the other genes in Lynch syndrome.
Overall risk of endometrial cancer is lower, and the age
of onset of endometrial cancer is later.
And so because of that, we then optimize or utilize this,
which the gene that the patient carries, to determine how their
gynecologic cancer risk should be
managed. So the high-risk gene carriers are basically getting their
hysterectomy and bilateral salpingo-oophorectomy at age 40.
For MSH6 carriers that, again, have a high endometrial
cancer risk, they really should have their hysterectomy at age 40, and the
oophorectomy can be potentially delayed until after menopause.
And for PMS2 carriers, because that risk of endometrial cancer
is lower
and doesn't arise until later in life, they can get their
hysterectomy and
ovaries out at age 50.
So this is thinking about Lynch syndrome at a gene-specific
level. But how about reduced penetrance genes within Lynch syndrome?
Oh, sorry, but before I get to that,
I did just want to highlight a few other difficulties that we
have when thinking about single variants in Lynch syndrome.
And that is that the cancer risk estimates that we
get, although we
give people, say, a colon cancer risk estimate or endometrial cancer risk
estimate, these risks do vary quite substantially,
even among single variants within Lynch syndrome.
So this is data looking at colorectal cancer risk on MSH2
carriers. And what you can see here is that over a lifetime, there's pretty
broad confidence intervals with this colorectal cancer risk
estimate. But this is colorectal cancer risk for one
specific MSH2 variant across many, many
families. And what you can see here is that even for this one variant, the
confidence intervals for cumulative colorectal cancer
risk are equally as broad, even for this single variant.
And interestingly, when you look at an individual's
risk of colorectal cancer for all MSH2
carriers, you likely have a population of MSH2 carriers
where their colon cancer risk essentially is population
risk. We don't know how to identify these people, but
certainly, this is the case. We see older
individuals who have had Lynch syndrome their whole life that really have not had
any cancer. And we see a population for this single
specific MSH2 variant where also there's likely some
individuals
that have a very low colorectal cancer risk.
But then at the same time, you have individuals
amongst all MSH2 carriers in this one particular variant who
have a near 100% risk of developing colorectal cancer.
And so even for this one particular variant, you have this wide
range of cancer risk that is possible.
So when we think about the reduced penetrance variants in Lynch syndrome, there
have been a few of them that have been described.
I'll point out a couple of them. This particular MLH1
variant,
it's a missense variant that's classified in ClinVar, and this
is a messy classification that leads to a lot of
difficulties with management of these individuals.
But you have one lab calling it a pathogenic
low penetrance variant, one calling it a likely pathogenic variant,
10 calling it a VUS, and one calling it a likely benign.
So, getting one of these particular variants
is very messy for clinicians.
This other MLH1 variant down here at the bottom was just recently published
on by Dan Buchanan and his group in Australia, but it's really still
globally classified as a VUS in ClinVar.
But the one that I'll talk a little bit more in more detail about is this
particular MSH6 missense variant.
And this one, if you look in ClinVar, basically all labs call it
pathogenic or likely pathogenic, but now you have one lab that's calling it
a likely pathogenic low penetrance variant.
And we presented some data on this in a collaboration with
University of Chicago and one of the genetic testing labs
at the CGA meeting last year, but I'll go through a little bit about what we
found.
So what we found was we looked at over a million individuals
who had, had hereditary cancer testing at a commercial lab.
Of these, about 3,000 had an MSH6 variant that
was found, and of the MSH6 carriers, about
4% had this particular MSH6
missense variant.
When you look at these cancer rates amongst these individuals,
those that had this particular missense MSH6 variant,
there were lower rates of most cancers, like colorectal cancer and uterine
cancer, compared to the group of all MSH6
carriers. And a larger percentage of these individuals were
unaffected by any Lynch syndrome cancer.
And when you try to translate this then into subsequent risks,
what we can see here is that the dark bars here are this MSH6
missense variant. And what you can see is that there's really not any statistically
increased risk of any Lynch syndrome cancer that we
found for this particular variant.
Whereas if you look at for all MSH6 pathogenic variants, colorectal,
ovarian, and uterine cancer are all increased as expected.
And importantly, when thinking about management for uterine cancer
risk, it was significantly lower for carriers of this
MSH6 missense variant.So we
think that this data -- hopefully this paper will come out in the
next six months or so. But we think that this particular variant
truly is a reduced penetrance Lynch syndrome
variant. And so how do we manage these individuals
clinically? So I think from a colonoscopy standpoint,
what you could consider doing is extending to the longest
interval that our guidelines will allow for colonoscopy, which would be
every three years. Most people in the field are not
using a three-year interval, so that would be extending the interval for colon
cancer screening for these individuals.
The gynecologic risk becomes much more difficult
to think about. And so potential options would be, since that
risk seems remarkably lower, do you defer hysterectomy until age
50 and potentially perform
the hysterectomy with oophorectomy at the same time?
Or for these individuals, do they need a hysterectomy, and could you potentially
consider foregoing that surgery?
So today that was a whirlwind tour.
I'm just going to leave you with a couple take-home points, and that's that
management of these reduced penetrance variants, I think, is very
difficult and is going to require extensive discussion
between patients and their healthcare providers.
If you do have a phenotype-directed approach that you can follow, then
I think using that makes it a lot easier to manage these
individuals. But that's a rarity in our
field, and I think we only have a few syndromes where that is a possibility.
Certainly, guidelines are going to need to continue to address the management of
these reduced penetrance variants, and we certainly need more
variant-specific cancer risk data that's out there.
And then if people do start using different management strategies, we need to learn
about the impact of these different management strategies on these
reduced penetrance carriers, and do they lead to any differences in
outcomes?
I'll just put in a plug for the CGA IGC.
If anybody's interested in hereditary GI cancer and wants to sit through a
wonderful three-day meeting, which will feel like it's only a day
because it's so interesting, please come join us in Denver.
And then I'd like to thank my lab group.
We do
like to pretend that we're polyps in the colon.
But we do a lot of basic science in this area as well, and so I'd
be happy to take any questions. Thank you.
Hi. Really interesting talk, all three of you.
I know you mentioned for MSH2,
4%
of the, I guess,
MSH2 carriers were from that variant.
Do you have an estimate on the other...
Out of all of the MSH2 pathogenic variants, how much-- or
MLH1, all the Lynch syndrome variants, how many would you think
are reduced penetrance
in these genes?
Yeah, that's a great question, and one that I
will not be able to answer. I think
finding a gene that's a true reduced penetrance gene
is very different than finding a gene that is associated with
probably a broad spectrum of cancer risk.
And so I think probably a small percentage
of the Lynch syndrome genes truly are reduced penetrance across the
board. I think within Lynch syndrome specifically, the bigger
challenge that we have is trying to understand why, even amongst single
variants, you see risk that spans the full spectrum
from population risk to almost certain risk of
developing cancer. And that's going to be important
for thinking about how these other factors play in, lifestyle
factors, maybe polygenic risk or other things like that.
Yeah. I think
on the case of BRCA1 and BRCA2,
if we take the functional analysis as a way to
estimate them, and maybe, I don't know if Fergus wants
to
make-- He's shaking his head.
But I think
we can find,
I would say,
a little bit between 20 and 30% of the variants,
or around 20% of the variants that show reduced
activity. Right? What's your denominator?
All variants? All the variants tested.
All the variants, including- I'm thinking about MAFs,
right? So if we think about MAFs,
in which
most of the variants are done in terms of,
first of all,
missense variants.
So if we look at all of them, how many of them would you
consider reduced activity?
5%. And how many of those you would think would
be true clinically relevant?
Right? So that's the answer, right? So I don't think we...
But-
What I'm saying is about in BRCA2, at least
14% of missense variants look like
they're 5% looked like they might be
bi-stable.
Okay.
So it's about 20% about 40%.
Yeah, but I think the question is also out of those 5%,
how many of them are going to be clinically relevant?
Because you may have some of these hypomorphs that could
not
just still have enough activity not to be clinically
relevant.Right. But
we have a 5% number that we may come back in a
few years to try to see if that was true or not.
What about for BRCA1?
You have it.
Oh. Now I have to say?
Yeah. I don't know, because
it's probably around the same, I would say.
Probably around the same.
Right.
But again, the caveat being that most of the things that we're saying
are about missense variants. And if you recall from
one of my slides, you can get hypomorphs,
and therefore reduced penetrance pathogenic variants in many
different types of molecular changes, right?
So even variants that in the past we thought were clear
loss of function, for example, truncations, we found
out that there is some sort of ways to
splice out that
particular variant and have a mini protein that
retains some of the residual function.
So even though variants that were clearly pathogenic
algorithmically, now we know that they may be reduced penetrance
variants as well.
Hi. Thank you for the talk. So it was very interesting.
Dr. Catona, I have a question for you.
I think you briefly mentioned polygenic risk.
And I think, when you look at these low penetrant genes and
we saw the conference intervals that are very wide, it's kind of
unclear. Do you think that
polygenic risk scores and common variants are going to be used in the clinic
more often to try to explain some of this risk?
Because you're seeing a lot of these earlier onset
colorectal cancers that are not necessarily explained by the
highly penetrant variants.
That's a great question. I think,
probably the likelihood of them being used is dependent on which cancer risk you're
talking about. I think, in say for example, breast
cancer, those models are a lot further
along. But, I think in the setting of Lynch syndrome, if you're thinking about
colorectal cancer risk, I don't think we're nearly
close to that level.
Yeah. No, and what I would say is Alvaro mentioned it in his talk.
We need to calibrate the risk first, right? And that's the problem.
We can't overlay polygenic risk on a variant that we
haven't yet calibrated. And even with a can-risk model that
I had mentioned in my talk, you don't put in the reduced penetrance
pathogenic variants in that program because you will
overestimate the risk, and you'll overestimate it by a lot, right?
So we don't use those models. We really don't have anything to use at
this point. So I think calibration would be
step one.
Can I ask a question?
Sure.
Okay.
I was curious, thinking about,
say a BRCA1,
if you had a reduced penetrance variant,
what would be the level of evidence that you would need or data you would need
to, say for example, for ovarian cancer, to
pull back on recommendations for doing a
oophorectomy?
I'll take a stab. But again, right now
we would need to be really confident it was less.
Again, in NCCN, we don't have specific risk
levels, but the best guess I have is 5%, right?
That's what we're saying right now.
So are we confident that it is less than
5%? And right now we're not with the reduced penetrance pathogenic
variants. I think there are efforts
nationally, internationally, through the biobanks, through the testing companies,
that are trying to refine the risk.
But Alvaro got into it with how are we going
to estimate variant specific risks and calibrate?
And there aren't that many variants that we can use to
calibrate on. So I know there are some
more common ones that we're trying to work on, but
that's what becomes a challenge. And those consensus variants that we
had, they had to be common enough, I guess, right, in order for the
labs to even see them and to call them out.
But we have a calibration problem right now, which I know
Alvaro, Fergus, a lot of people are working on it.
I actually had a question for you. MSH6, what about the functional data for that
reduced penetrance variant?
Because you talked about the family history data, which is compelling,
but I just thought-
Yeah
... the basic science piece would be interesting, too.
Yeah.
Certainly. We haven't actually studied that
particular variant, but we've been in talks with some
collaborators to do some more in-depth functional studies.
Because that would be a nice way to
potentially validate these big differences in cancer
risk that we're seeing.
Absolutely.
Yeah. No, I think just making a... Oh, please go ahead.
So
actually, I was looking at what you guys were discussing
because
what I was thinking is about this
low penetrance, especially when you see a
variation
within the same mutation in the risk of the
cancer
that you are showing on the
population. So
about the multigene thing. So
BRCA is a complex of proteins, right?
So if you have a mutation that decreases
the activityBut
there is another protein in the complex which
also has a variant that decreases activity or
whatever. Then these two things together
potentiate each other. So you would have to
consider in the context of all the proteins that form the
complex.
And
so what I'm thinking, what do you think
of using artificial intelligence to help you make
this classification of how to
weight
how heavy these mutations or variants would
actually affect protein function?
Because then you have to look at the other proteins in the complex as well,
right?
Yeah. Thank you for that question.
I think you pointed out an even different layer
that we haven't discussed today, which was basically
I would make the analogy that this would be synthetic
hypermorphism instead of synthetic lethality. Right?
So what you're saying is that even variants
that we now score and they have
enough function,
but they may have reduced function, that when you look at them alone,
they should be fine. But now in combination with a
reduced variant in BRCA2 or
PALB2, we may actually have something as a
global thing that is impactful, right?
And I think this is certainly a possibility.
I think that right now
we already use some of artificial intelligence,
via AlphaFold and AlphaMisSense, to do some of these
predictions. And AlphaFold is now kind of much
better as well to look at complexes.
Now, again, it all comes back to validation.
We don't have enough data yet to
do the calibration, and we can predict
something. Prediction will give us a score.
The question is, where is the threshold of that score that we're going
to lead to that?
So,
maybe what I want to say is how accurate are these
tests when you only test that protein
specifically, not in the context that it acts
physiologically?
So as far as we can
use the known variants,
they are extremely good if we judge by specificity
and sensitivity. Now, whether they are extremely good
to model these more moderate cases that you're
talking about, it's something that we don't know.
So some of those other
as part of the complex, like BRCA2 and
PALB2, are partners, right? So within the
complex, we are testing other
inherited cancer genes. I don't know that we're testing
all of them in the complex, but that at least is giving us some
additional information, would you say, in terms of
pathogenicity within the complex?
Because, again, it would be pretty rare for people to have
more than one
pathogenic variant. I mean, we see it.
Well, but that's the thing. I think it will be pretty rare for people to
have a variant that has a significant
impact. But now if we move and we think about the
BRCA variants, that would be, for example, in the polygenic
risk score. They have minor effects, but it's just in
combination. So perhaps this will actually come out
as
another component of the polygenic risk score.
That is an excellent point, because the
I157T variant in CHEK2 is
one of the
biggest signals in some of these PRS models for breast
cancer.
Thank you very much. I think we got to
the end of it in time.
Thank you for the fantastic discussion,
and thank you for the speakers, and we'll be around if you want to discuss
more about that as well. Thank you very much